[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a áfrica siete días
hasta su magazine 100 dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es andrés
meza y estoy aquí en reemplazo de mi
compañera liliana valencia a
continuación nuestros titulares a los 84
años murió el ex presidente de argelia
abdelaziz buteflika el mandatario
gobernó el país durante 20 años se
renunció en 2019 a raíz de las protestas
que rechazaban su intención de
postularse para un nuevo mandato
las fuerzas francesas mataron al líder
del autoproclamado estado islámico en el
sahel así lo informó el presidente galo
en manuel macrón oficiales detallaron
que la muerte se produjo el 17 de agosto
cuando viajaba por malos
en guinea la junta militar que tomó el
poder el pasado 5 de septiembre aseguró
que no liberará al depuesto presidente
alpha condé e informó que el
exmandatario se encuentra detenido
dentro del país además destacó que no le
preocupan las nuevas sanciones impuestas
por la comunidad económica de estados de
áfrica occidental
empezamos en argelia porque hubo duelo
nacional tras la muerte del ex
presidente argelino abdelaziz buteflika
quien murió a los 84 años el pasado 17
de septiembre el cuerpo del exmandatario
será llevado al palacio del pueblo antes
de ser sepultado en el sector de los
mártires en el cementerio de al ahli a
en argel la capital del país un lugar
reservado para los héroes de la
independencia buteflika se mantuvo
durante 20 años en el poder y se vio
obligado a abandonar la política en los
últimos años a causa de su enfermedad en
el siguiente reportaje repasamos quién
fue abdelaziz buteflika
cuando llegó al poder en 1999 abdelaziz
buteflika hizo renacer la esperanza en
el seno de la población argelina el país
se tambaleaba después de cerca de una
década de guerra civil producto de la
violencia entre islamistas y la fuerza
de seguridad que se cobró 150 mil vidas
candidatos del ejército y el lúdico en
la carrera luego de la retirada de sus
adversarios quienes denunciaron un
supuesto fraude el día previo al
escrutinio se hizo con las riendas de un
país desgarrado por la guerra llegó el
momento de detener la división de acabar
con los costos la mayoría del pueblo
argelino de todos los sudaneses y todo
tipo de sensibilidad que tiene la
suficiente capacidad de entender todo el
mal que se le ha hecho a nuestro país
anoche el presidente argelino se
presentaba como un constructor de la paz
en 2004 fue reelegido y siguió con su
objetivo de la pacificación pidiendo
perdón a los islamistas que seguían en
la clandestinidad una elección política
que denunciaron su opositor es abdelaziz
buteflika cultivó su imagen de garante
de la estabilidad junto con sus
homólogos extranjeros y para quedarse en
el poder modificó la constitución
buscar su tercer mandato encontró poca
resistencia en un país todavía
paralizado por el recuerdo de sus años
del plomo nuevamente reelegido sus
opositores alertaron de la confiscación
del poder por parte del jefe de estado
víctima donde rama cerebral en 2013 el
presidente fue reelegido por un cuarto
mandato al año siguiente pero sus
apariciones públicas eran cada vez más
escasas en un país minado por la
corrupción y la pobreza muchos decían
que ya no era apto para gobernar pero el
10 de febrero de 2019 confirmó su
candidatura y se perfiló para un quinto
mandato esa fue la gota que colmó el
vaso para los manifestantes argelinos
decenas de miles salieron a protestar en
las calles por primera vez tras más de
20 años una movilización tenía tal
magnitud en argelia
fuertemente presionado y después de más
de cinco semanas de disputas quien fue
la cabeza del ejército ahmed gaid salah
terminó por arrebatarle el poder a quien
lo promovió abdelaziz buteflika fue
obligado de emitir
las fuerzas francesas mataron al líder
del estado islámico en el sahel adnan
abu walid al saharaui la acción que es
considerada primordial contra los
extremistas fue dada a conocer por el
presidente manuel macrón pero su
gobierno explicó que la muerte del jefe
del grupo extremista se produjo el 17 de
agosto cuando un dron impactó la moto en
la que viajaba por mali rosa pérez
masdéu con los detalles
las autoridades francesas se felicitan
han matado a su principal objetivo en el
sahel el líder y fundador de la filial
del grupo estado islámico en la región
adnan abu walid el shaarawy quien
previamente fue miembro del frente
polisario y de al qaeda en el magreb
adnan abu walid al zarautz y jefe del
grupo terrorista estado islámico en el
gran sáhara ha sido y neutralizado por
las fuerzas francesas se trata de un
nuevo gran éxito en el combate que
llevamos a cabo contra los grupos
terroristas en el sahel
adnan abu ali tal saharaui es
considerado responsable de múltiples
ataques en la llamada zona de las tres
fronteras un territorio que abarca parte
de mali níger y burkina faso las
autoridades de francia aseguran que fue
el líder del estado islámico en el sahel
quien ordenó el asesinato de 6
trabajadores humanitarios franceses el 9
de agosto de 2020 una orden de ejecución
entre muchas longhini sesión silver
eagle mo la organización también atacaba
autoridades civiles y tradicionales en
el marco de ejecuciones públicas
sangrientas son glantz
sistema chico filme al antón
sistemáticamente filmadas y dirigidas al
propio emir luces timón que ulises
estimamos que el estado islámico en el
sahel es responsable de la muerte de
entre dos mil y tres mil civiles desde
2013 y precisó que la gran mayoría de
víctimas son de confesión musulmana
son de confesión musulmana la duda es
quién sustituirá al líder al frente del
estado islámico del sahel o si el vacío
propulsar a la fuerza de al qaeda en la
región el ministro de exteriores de
francia pidió que las autoridades
estatales actúen para controlar el
territorio los hechos se producen en el
marco de la reducción de la presencia
militar francesa en el sahel anunciada
por macrón en junio el presidente quiere
que la intervención extranjera en la
zona esté asegurada por una alianza
internacional
la junta militar que tomó el poder en
guinea el pasado 5 de septiembre aseguró
que no liberará al depuesto presidente
alpha condé e informó que el
exmandatario se encuentra dentro del
país el jefe de la junta militar el
coronel mamá de dumbo ya resaltó es
resaltó que los representantes de la
comunidad económica de estados de áfrica
occidental cedeao se reunieron con conde
y destacó que no le preocupa las nuevas
sanciones impuestas por este bloque para
forzar a una formación de un gobierno
democrático en este país
y
hubo conversaciones honestas y sinceras
entre la delegación de la cedeao y el
presidente mamá de atún bulla sobre el
primer punto la liberación inmediata del
ex presidente la delegación pudo
reunirse con el ex presidente y
agradeció al presidente de un goya por
facilitar la reunión está claro para
todos que el ex presidente permanecerá
en guinea sin embargo se hará todo lo
posible para mantenerlo a salvo física y
mentalmente
y en medio de reportes que sugieren la
posible llegada a mali de mercenarios
rusos damos un vistazo al grupo warner
una opaca compañía de contratistas
militares rusos presentes en varios
conflictos en el mundo combatientes de
confianza de moscú pero a los que no
reconoce oficialmente
para amnistía internacional son el
ejército secreto de vladimir putin
[Aplausos]
compuesto por entre 2.500 y 5.000
mercenarios son rusos y extranjeros
desde 2014 el grupo warner ha operado
según esta investigación en conflictos
globales donde el kremlin tiene
intereses estratégicos
mucho cuál es el objetivo principal de
cualquier empresa militar privada
defender los intereses de un gobierno si
no puede utilizar el ejército regular
el objetivo son los ingresos económicos
y la posibilidad de tomar control de un
gran mercado de recursos petroleros para
nuestro país
el grupo está presente en 12 países pero
surgió a la luz por primera vez en
ucrania donde sus mercenarios lucharon
junto a los separatistas pro rusos y
finalmente apoyaron la anexión de crimea
por parte de moscú
desde entonces sus contratistas han
luchado junto al ejército nacional sirio
en la guerra civil han reforzado las
tropas que han entregado armas al
general rebelde califa captar en libia
y proveyeron seguridad a los asediados
presidentes en venezuela y república
centroafricana
en 2019 ayudaron a reprimir las
manifestaciones contra el hombre fuerte
de sudán omar al-bashir
a cambio el grupo obtiene dinero en
efectivo y en algunos países ricos en
petróleo oro y diamantes derechos de
extracción sin embargo los métodos del
grupo han alarmado a la onu y a varias
ong los contratistas de wágner han sido
acusados de llevar a cabo ejecuciones
violaciones y torturas en el curso de
sus misiones estas preocupaciones
aumentaron con el asesinato de tres
periodistas que investigaban las
actividades del grupo en república
centroafricana en 2018 las autoridades
rusas han negado repetidamente que los
contratistas de wágner cumplen sus
órdenes pero las fotografías y el
testimonio de los propios mercenarios de
wágner demuestran que sí
cientos de personas se tomaron las
calles de la capital tunecina para
manifestar su oposición a la decisión
del presidente caixa 7 el pasado julio
de asumir plenamente la autoridad
ejecutiva en el país sus oponentes
acusan al mandatario de haber actuado de
manera inconstitucional paralelamente se
organizó una contramanifestación en
apoyo a la decisión del presidente los
manifestantes en la mayoría de ellos
simpatizantes de nada el partido
conservador es la amistad con más
escaños en el parlamento se congregaron
en el centro de la ciudad y denunciaron
lo que ellos consideran un golpe contra
la democracia
ahora vamos a etiopía donde el pasado 11
de septiembre se celebró el año nuevo el
segundo país más poblado de áfrica
cuenta con un calendario de 13 meses que
comienzan en septiembre y tiene un
retraso de 7 a 8 años con respecto al
calendario gregoriano por lo que el 18
de septiembre fue el primer día de 2014
para los etíopes las celebraciones
suelen estar repletas de cantos y bailes
pero este año cierne una nube sobre las
festividades en particular para las
personas de la región de tigre la
economía está en crisis con una
inflación que superó el 30 por ciento el
mes pasado
en este mercado en addis abeba no hay la
multitud que se esperaría ver a sólo
unas horas del comienzo del año nuevo
etíope
muchos no están de humor para una fiesta
durante casi un año la guerra ha asolado
el norte del país con consecuencias
nefastas en la economía de la nación así
como un impacto en el poder adquisitivo
de los etíopes y
el aumento de los precios de los bienes
está afectando nuestra economía y
nos está afectando a todos
la inflación nos hace la vida cada vez
más difícil
según naciones unidas la guerra en tigre
le ha costado al país unos mil millones
de dólares los combates también han
interrumpido los suministros y el dueño
de este negocio está preocupado
actualmente los precios de los productos
han aumentado y la gente no puede
permitirse comer aquí el gobierno ha
continuado con su retórica bélica
llamando a acabar con los rebeldes de
tigre pero muchas de las personas que
hacen sus compras de año nuevo aquí solo
quieren una cosa más
toda la vida será estable cuando el país
esté en paz garcelán canela
el objetivo peces están preocupados y
ansiosos versión versa lo general y
estamos ayunando y llorando y anoche en
casa de dios nos de un nuevo año con
amor y alkarbide ambiental sin embargo
la paz no parece ser una prioridad para
ninguna de las partes en su mensaje de
año nuevo el jefe del frente de
liberación popular de tigre dijo a sus
seguidores que no descansarán hasta que
sus enemigos sean destruidos
y finalizamos esta edición de áfrica
siete días con música porque llegan
desde uganda los más acá kits un grupo
de niños que se ha robado el corazón del
mundo con sus pegajosos bailes los
dejamos con su más reciente lanzamiento
'dancing with you
máscaras africanas muy dio
al canfranc
aunque más líquido y soja
cuidado
[Música]
dónde está